New Orleans mayor that's Mitch Landrieu
is opening up about his decision to
remove four Confederate monuments from
his City
Marilyn drew recently took 60 minutes to
a shed where the statues of generals
robert e lee and PGT Beauregard now Stan
the Democrat also removed statues last
year of Confederate President Jefferson
Davis in the Battle of Liberty Place
monument that statue commemorate an
attempt by white supremacist to
overthrow the city's integrated
government after the Civil War
mayor Landrieu discusses a path he took
toward removing the monuments in his new
book in the shadow of statues a white
southerner confronts history mayor
Landrieu joins us at the table hello
white southerner I was so moved by your
book I have to say I was I was very
moved by it there were so many things
and I didn't know and didn't really
think about until I was reading your
book but this all started from a
conversation with went in Marsalis who
was an old friend of yours it did the
context was of course you know the city
was destroyed by Katrina and thanked the
rest of Americans for helping to stand
back up but as we were building the city
back and reconstructing it the mantra
was don't put it back like it was put it
back the way it should have been if he
would have gotten it right the first
time and so as we begin to prepare for
our 300th anniversary which is in a
couple of weeks by the way I asked
wenting to help me and he said well I'll
help you he said you really ought to
think about taking down the robert e lee
statue and I said why would I do that
and he said well have you ever thought
about who put it there why it's there or
what impact it has on people like me and
then the next thing he said really just
exploded my brain which was that you
know Louis Armstrong left here and
didn't want to come back because of that
statute and when he said that the notion
of the great diaspora five million
african-americans who fled the south
after the Civil War and really just
troubled me greatly and I told him that
I would look into it and it did and you
to put it in context about what it means
though why it is so painful well when
you when you see it from Winton's eyes
so you see it from the eyes of a young
african-american girl in the city that's
60% african-american those monuments
were put up by people for a reason which
was to send a message that
notwithstanding the fact that the
Confederacy lost the war that that idea
was still in the control of the south
and much like Jim Crow logic much like
separate but equal
much like the laws that prohibited
african-americans from following whites
in a car on the highway and passing them
these statutes were put up well after
the Civil War for the specific purpose
of removing the Confederacy which of
course you know was designed to destroy
the nation over the cause of slavery and
the reaction when you did this was you
couldn't find a crane among other well
it was a very emotional reaction we had
a number of long debates in public
hearings in the City Council court races
but after the decision was made legally
to take them down even the a powerful
mayor of a city that was rebuilding the
entire city airport's riverfront schools
I couldn't find anybody to give me a
crane and I couldn't find a crane
operator which really began to introduce
me into the concept of institutional
racism and what that really meant and
you could have the law on your side but
if you didn't have the levers of power
or the money or the equipment you were
basically screwed forgive the language
but you couldn't get anything done and
that story came back to me powerfully
because I've heard that from a lot of my
friends for many years over over a long
time in the book in the book you
mentioned race and you say here's what I
know about race you can't go over it you
can't go under it you can't go around it
you have to go through it that's a
difficult thing to do well it's very
hard and of course dr. King has kind of
showed us the way but there are people
who were still with us so I consider to
be saints like John Lewis who as you may
recall and I talked about this in the
book we're standing on the Edmund Pettus
Bridge and he knew he was about to get
hit by that Sheriff and he never moves
and he's walked us through this
difficult perhaps because we really
don't know how to talk about it in the
country it's a very uncomfortable and
the point that I'm making in the book is
based on my experience it's very hard
but you have to talk about it and you
have to walk through it we have to give
each other a lot of room in the book
really is more of an invitation than it
is a judgment or an accusation for
people to see the world differently
based on what the real history was so
how do you have that conversation with
people who don't immediate who aren't
giving you the crane how do you how do
you have that conversation well you do
it by taking down mind image you do it
by giving speech as you do it by getting
people around the table to actually say
can you see the world from our
perspective and so it's it is the book
is about race but writ large it's about
discrimination it's about really getting
back to what makes us really great
Americans which is judging people based
on that behavior not what they look like
where they come from what their religion
is what their origin of the nation
really on behavior that's the idea of
America which makes us great but you
said Mara whenever you would waver
listen you got death threats you were
threatened yeah when it came to take
those statues down you had to have
police escorts sharpshooters yeah
wearing wearing wearing on what do you
call it the bulletproof vests so they
had to be totally covered it was that
dangerous but you said whenever you
wavered you would think about two
numbers which I thought was interesting
what were their number one of them was
how many African Americans were enslaved
which is around five or six million and
the others how many people were killed
in the Civil War at six hundred thousand
plus more and the sacrifice that they
made and by the way I'm not the first
one that ever tried this they've been so
many people that have had more difficult
struggles than this that are too
numerous to name right now but you could
go back my dad told me well he was
afraid because he was my he had been the
mayor of the city of New Orleans he knew
what the issue of race was about his
life was threatened when he was 29 years
old and I was in utero when he voted
against the segregation package when
Jimmy Davis and a lot of folks were
around so he knew that this was not a
safe thing having said that a lot of
other people have made greatest
sacrifices and I will ever make to this
particular cause so when that happened I
just tried to remember the other people
that that had courage and and just kind
of kept walking and a lot of people
helped this was a this was a communal
laughter this is not something clearly
that I did by myself while the first one
to actually talk about it I loved that
you wanted to be an actor before poet I
absolutely did I still do we dare think
Mitch Landrieu 2020 no ma'am
okay but thanks for thanks for what does
moon think yeah it was pretty sober
about it all - I mean that's a that's
always a tough road right mayor Landrieu
it's always good to see you always good
to have you in the morning thank you so
much for having me
and the shadow of statues is on sale now
wherever you like to buy your books